so tonight a group of parents and other
community members met to talk about some
of their frustrations over this new
hybrid plan brian yeah they're upset
about the rest of this year and say
there's no reason
everyone can't be back by august 8 news
now reporter madison kimbrough was there
at that meeting tonight madison
yes now for a long time kids have been
learning like this right here at the
kitchen table
but we spoke to some parents tonight who
are frustrated and wanting to know when
their kids can return back to the
classroom
full time since vaccines are available
to teachers
we all expect our kids to be back in
school
and for sports to be back by fall
of of this year by august of this year
tonight's gathering comes after the
recent ccsd survey
in which parents only had two options to
choose from have their kids do distant
virtual learning or have them learn
through the hybrid model while parents
understand that these are options for
this school year
the fear is that ccsd will use the info
as an outline for the 2021-2022 school
term
the hybrid model the way it's now
outlined our kids would only go back to
school two days a week
and instead of getting five days of
interaction with their
teachers online right now they would
only receive two
and the other three they would be left
to do online work on their own
many parents spoke out stating that
their child is deteriorating mentally
and physically
by being isolated from the classroom and
their peers
as time has gone on i've seen that the
social emotional
and academic harm that this
prolonged absence of being in the school
has caused
no longer outweighs the benefits of
keeping them out of school
currently ccsd has no plans of allowing
kids back into the classroom full time
but are offering the hybrid model for
pre-k through third graders
starting march first starting march
first
and we reached out to superintendent
jara to address the parents issues at
hand but we have yet to hear back
reporting live madison kimbrough 8 news
now